daley is the most decorated british
diver of all time and has competed in
the last four summer olympics at the
2008 beijing games his first olympics
daley was just 14 years old in his book
coming up for air daley gets candid
about what was really happening in his
life on and off the diving board he
joins us right now how are you doing i'm
doing good thank you for having me of
course now you start your book off
talking about that triumphant bronze
medal in the 2012 games in london how
you felt directionless yeah why start
off the book like that because i think
lots of people in life sometimes i'd
visualize that moment since i was nine
years old i used to have this little
medal book and at the front of it i drew
a picture of myself doing a handstand
with the olympic rings at nine years old
so i had visualized that moment for my
whole life and worked towards it and
then once it got there i won my medal
and then it was that moment of what's
next and i felt like i had lost all
purpose and
lots of people experience what athletes
sometimes call olympic blues where it's
all gone and you don't know what's going
to be next and where are you going to go
you have to go back to training your
life continues as normal you come from
this high
and
it took me a while to find you know in
that period of time i was also
struggling with my sexuality in a very
public way and figuring out who i was as
a person so it was a really intense year
after those olympics and you talk about
coming out i love you right so really
poignantly about that moment because you
said you knew that you were different as
a little boy you knew that all along and
the struggle about whether to come out
not to come out you were very afraid
and your the reaction was mixed within
your family members yes but once you did
it though tom you said you felt this
huge sense of relief
i don't think i really understood how
much
it was weighing down on me until i was
able to get rid of
stop hiding and stop being you know i
was going on dates with my now husband
with my friends to try and you would
take a female friend yeah i would take
my friend sophie with me because i
didn't want people to find out that i
was gay and it was this terrifying thing
and you know i was told by management at
the time that i was going to lose
sponsors and i was going to lose not be
able to go and compete in certain
countries so it was a really terrifying
experience but then coming out and you
know the public being really supportive
and it just yeah i don't know it really
allowed me to really fly in the way that
i wanted to i was really struck by the
parts in the book where you talk about
body image which is not something that
people first of all associate with men
generally and then that people associate
with an olympic athlete i have this
distinct memory as a kid coming out of
the pool my stepfather pinching my belly
fat it was like the first time i
realized like i even have a body yeah
right and so you had a coach say you
were overweight and it really stuck with
you could you just talk a little bit
about how that affected you and where
you are with it now yeah i mean like
similar to you there was this moment
where i was told that i was overweight
and had to lose weight and i had never
seen my body in a way that people would
look at it and be like oh you're fat or
you're overweight or you need to so all
of a sudden my body wasn't just what i
was using to dive well it was this thing
that people were looking at and you know
when i'm diving there there isn't much
place to hide there's nothing yeah
there's not many people that say that
they can they wear more to bed than they
do to work and that's me so there was
this moment where i just really
struggled with
the fact that every time i went on to
poolside i would feel like my coaches
and people were looking at me and it
really started to play with my head and
which led to
an eating disorder and feeling like i
wasn't able to
get the best out of my performance
because i was sacrificing it for the way
that i looked and you know still
something that i struggle with today but
i was really embarrassed almost to talk
about it because like you say men don't
talk about body images
much more confident people think and
yeah it looks so good i mean you you
write about it takes 1.6 seconds to hit
the water yeah we don't have a long time
to look at your body
but when you but for the olympics a lot
of people knew you was a guy that
knitted yes sitting there knitting went
viral for it if you went viral for that
you were surprised that it got that much
attention yeah i mean i started knitting
um just before the start of lockdown and
it was my work look at you i was
knitting away in the stands on poolside
everywhere and it was mainly my way of
being able to find something to rest and
recover and i feel like it was my super
power to allow me to stop overthinking
well we're looking forward to that uh
tom daley crochet clothing line yeah oh
yeah oh no that's made with love is that
but right now you can get the book
coming up for air it's on sale today we